[Music]
all right today's question comes from
cassie in wisconsin my husband and i
recently decided to move closer to
family
but since making that decision my sense
of security is crumbling
we lost two businesses when the pandemic
started we sold our house for a good
price however the area we are moving to
is more expensive
we are completely debt free but with the
current economic landscape i'm freaking
out that we're putting ourselves in a
shaky position
how do we know that we haven't made a
huge mistake
dave how do you tell somebody
to know if they haven't made a huge
mistake i kind of have a default answer
to that but before i just throw it out
there
i um
[Music]
you know i it's not permanent
you can undo anything you're doing like
if you go there and it doesn't work out
you can leave
that's how do you know you haven't made
it so it's not a huge mistake you might
have made a mistake yeah you might screw
it up you don't know
but is is it life-threatening no no
is it going to ruin the rest of your
life financially no
not unless you stay there in the middle
of the huge mistake
but if you get over there and it's a
mistake then you leave
yeah but i can't tell what all's going
on here
if you sold everything and you lost your
business
and you don't have any incomes and
you're moving to an expensive area that
would be like
a good thing for you to be freaking out
because you don't have any income right
you should be freaking out uh but that
that's gonna happen if you stay where
you are
you don't have any income so the lack of
income that i
think i'm reading here is um
you know you're debt-free but you don't
have income right you still have to make
money even when you're debt-free
and i read this more i'm assuming that
they've got
they figured out they got to get jobs
i read this more as something that's
happened to me several times which is
i know what the right decision to make
is and i make that decision
and i still wake up in six months and
you get that
do we do the right thing and you just
feel like you're on unstable ground
so you got to circle back to again those
the data
right the facts why'd you do this in the
first place is it the right move yes it
is
you probably woke up and you don't have
any community anymore and you got to go
make friends again and you got to go
figure out
all those things that are not fun to do
but that slowly help your feet settle
into the
to the sidewalk right well and you
decide to move closer to family and the
great news is you're closer to family
the bad news is
you're closer to a family that's right
but that might be sinking into the
fairyland
view of being near mom might not be
quiet now mom's nearer to you
oh my god but i've left
because jobs went somewhere new i knew
all the reasons why i left that job
and then dave whenever they finally
replaced me at that old position
i think oh for i don't know why it just
gets me a little bit and other the the
world keeps turning without me there
yeah you really realize you're it's not
yeah we can exist with that or old
employees call and say hey
that cool thing idea you had they just
changed it now they're doing something
else it's three four years ago
i still think oh man that was a good i i
suddenly realized i had a little bit of
my identity still attached back there
right well that would be human nature
that's right and so i gotta
acknowledge it and then i gotta realize
i live here now and as you pointed out
how do you know it's not a mistake you
don't so live into it make the best of
it it's an adventure
you realize it's not great move it's an
adventure baby this is how it works
yeah i think that's true and you're
debt-free you set yourself
up for this kind of move right yeah
there's a
uh an old movie i think it was called
parenthood with steve martin
oh yeah there's a bunch of one-liners in
that thing that are fabulous
uh but at the end of the i mean he goes
through all this turmoil with family
stuff and it's just driving him crazy
all this anxiety all this
angst and jobs and loss and all this
i i mean i don't even remember what all
it is but it's like a constant the whole
movie is a constant state of crap
and at the end of it he's getting on a
roller coaster and he's right he's
riding the roller coaster
of life yep it's the metaphor and he's
enjoying
the ride that's right with the ups and
the downs and it's a beautiful scene at
the end the beautiful metaphor for the
whole thing
because that is parenthood yeah yeah
it's going to be you know that is moving
close to family that is changing cities
it's an adventure
so uh it's still
let's let's say you move um from
uh what the city you're in and you move
to the more expensive place
and two years from now you're miserable
uh economically it's not working out
relationally it's not working out
and it we would if you want to call it a
huge mistake you can call it a huge
mistake
if you just want to call it a mistake we
can call it a mistake so two years from
now
what would you do what could you do uh
load up the truck and move back right or
go somewhere else
or start a third possible city
that's the beauty of america it is still
as many
many people don't agree with this but it
is still free yeah and you can just
decide
i don't want to live in california
anymore right
and a whole bunch of people did and they
left oh man they did
yeah and i don't want to live in new
york anymore and a whole bunch of people
did
and they left right and uh
you know and i don't want to live near
my mother and you leave
right and i do want to live near my
mother so you go right
and you you know these are options you
can just decide and
so the cool thing about a decision is if
it's the wrong one make another one yeah
and just because it's uncomfortable
doesn't mean you made the wrong decision
right and we see that with 100 of change
is going to be uncovered there you go we
see that with breakups with moves with
new jobs
they're always uncomfortable right and
we we often we're so obsessed with our
feelings
that we feel less than what we imagine
perfect is going to be and we think oh
we screwed that up no you didn't
he didn't right it's going to be
uncomfortable for a season until you get
friends to get a community to get a
church
do you all find your date spot do you
find the place where everybody knows
your name whatever those are
and or two years you wake up and realize
this isn't the right move for us
yeah let's get out of here one of our
operating board members wrote the uh
wrote our ramsey newsletter last week
and the whole opening thing was i hope
this week has been uncomfortable for you
i hope this week you've had conflict
that was healthy yeah i hope this week
that you've been pushed to be better
i hope this week you've been done and
the uncomfortable conversation pushing
someone else to be better
i hope this week that you've gone
outside your comfort zone and it scared
the crap out of you
i hope this because otherwise you're not
living that's exactly right
yeah that's right we are addicted to
comfort in our
society yeah that's very very good stuff
very good stuff so hang in there cassie
hang in there yeah
make the move it's an adventure ride the
roller coaster
do it have at it and if it's bad just
undo it
yeah just go back you're debt-free for a
reason i don't know if i should pay off
my house
i don't know i've got the money in my
checking account i don't know if i
should pay off my house
pay it off pay it off if you hate being
debt free
you can go get a mortgage
[Laughter]
people people don't do it but if you get
in there and you go you know this is the
dumbest thing i ever did
i hate being debt-free i can't stand it
i really enjoyed having that mortgage
payment
i want another one the mortgage company
will sign your butt right up
that's the beauty of america you'll be
right back in there
in no time if you pay off all your
credit cards and cut them all up
and you don't you don't uh like it they
will give you another one there'll be
one in your mailbox tuesday don't worry
about it
you'll have another shot oh my gosh
i'll give a dead person and a dog a
credit card so definitely give you one